[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، وصل اليوم الحاسم في
ليونيل ميسي مسيرته الخامسة
عرض مليء بالعناوين في جميع أنحاء العالم مع
برشلونة ومع ذلك فهو يفتقر إلى
الفوز بالجائزة الكبرى La Gran Victoria مع
فاز المنتخب الأرجنتيني بالكأس
أخذت أمريكا في عام 2020 وزنًا ثقيلًا للغاية
مهم بالنسبة له من وراء ظهره
تلك التي كانت الجماهير الأرجنتينية
يدعي أنه يعرف أكثر من
لا أحد أن هذه هي الفرصة العظيمة لا
آخر فرصة كبيرة
فرصة لديك في حياتك المهنية
السن لأخذ الأرجنتين إلى
فوز
العكس هو كرواتيا ، فريق من
أقوى من الذي ستواجهه
الأرجنتين بعد هولندا
عندما حقا كأس العالم
بدأت بجدية للمختارين
ليونيل دي سكالوني غدًا عظيم
ليلة ميسي ستكون قادرة على إعادة التأكيد في
كل شيء قضيته قبل 15 عامًا
مهنة تثبت في التاريخ
الأرجنتينيون ينتظرونه من كرة القدم
جزء كبير من سيليست والحلم الأبيض
يعتمد عليه
[تصفيق]